[Music]
welcome everybody to the h3 soundboard
experience got a lot of complaints about
the soundboard and I hear you most
definitely
welcome to the soundboard experience
today is we return with the wonderful
great excellent and most beloved
videogame dunkey and Lea who are
currently facing the wall I feel like
I'm in the Blair Witch Project thank you
guys we are on this side okay welcome
everybody thank you guys it's very much
I like that you guys you don't want to
distract me you don't want to make it
weird to the wall it's very appreciative
love that today's episode before I
forget is sponsored by you to meet honey
and quip welcome back ela by the way so
thankful to have you back I've been in
the trenches taking grenades how many
offices do they do without you
I think god I was gonna monitor oh good
to have you back crazy
you didn't get into trouble well leah
was just telling me in the last episode
as many of you did well it's okay no I
got to confront my you know my
shortcomings that I overplayed the
Roseanne's now I didn't see any of that
what you know I have one too and I'm
gonna be using you know hit me with the
cricket I've got great news guys we're
gonna be playing another round today of
know you're me
that's right you know your meme
featuring the one and only videogames
dunkey sitting across from me today so
to play call in to 808 hot mean that is
our real number 808 hot meme for a
chance to win a new samsung galaxy s 9
plus all right are you guys doing
[Music]
thinking about hitting you with rose am
but i'm not gonna ride that button so
what what brings you guys out to LA well
basically our house is it a it's just to
get out kind of just get out stretch
your legs take a trip nice see something
besides Wisconsin mm-hmm
like the three blocks around like what
are you what goes on in Wisconsin well
we play tennis yeah you do terribly not
worry about us no we don't keep score
getting out there and how frequently do
you guys play tennis you know if we're
doing really good we'll go every week
but you know might make some break weeks
charge yeah but the worse you are at
tennis the more exercise you want them
getting we're really yeah you guys would
like being out here in LA I will say by
the way the blue bird that you guys took
that we called for you they take two
hours of which I'm very grateful and
sorry for yeah you know a relaxing uh
journey stopping and starting you don't
have traffic in Wisconsin right you do
but I don't know
you I don't know it's not you have like
people on motorcycles over here going
through like the blinds
yeah Wisconsin like you have like an old
grandma like driving on the wrong side
of a comeback yeah
Ellie's driving nuts though the
motorcycle between the car is always
struck me as very oddly reckless
behavior it is but I think when you're
on the motorcycle you feel like you know
better than everyone I'm on a [ __ ]
motorcycle grandma I don't know they
scare me
because like all the sudden their
recklessness becomes my problem because
well I'm in traffic I'm not paying that
close attention to like what's in
between me and the next bar yeah all the
Sun I'm switching lanes yeah we have a
word for them she call some ancient
aliens what the motorcycle it's anyone
who's like you know they're driving the
wrong way down the road or they're like
just stopped it's ancient aliens the
crossing between old people that just
can't see and college kids that are just
dumb as hell that's just a mishmash
yeah irony you know that guy from H an
alien the crazy aliens that's who's
driving oh yeah exactly
well clearly they're like not in this
world right now they're like just it's
like what do you do you guys ever been
in a car crash ah I have not been
ancient alien she's written a lot of
accidents maybe she is after it
seriously never her fault but she's
always gentlemen what was it like what
am i ah one with this some lady just
went through a red light
oh that was probably the worst one was
it pretty serious yeah I was pretty
scared were you injured no we're fine
what did the car hit your side yeah
damn our car didn't get killed though
their their car did what part what car
were you in what car with aunt do you
remember how old are you hmm 17 or 16
you're survivor that's pretty scary
getting Johnny boned at a red light
because here it was you know the back
okay
you spun out maybe probably I can't
remember you blocking it out of your
memory suit just once
I kind of like I was someone was parked
like in the middle of the street I was
gonna go and then all of a sudden they
started to do parked in Miller Street
yeah like he was waiting for something
waiting for you so he could hate me but
it wasn't nothing serious it's all good
I mean that's it my dad really someone
was my dad is an ancient alien he's a he
is a liability have we told this story
about how in Mexico like probably my dad
is a psycho don't ever get in a car was
there you have like one star you were
driving around all day and nobody would
ever get like I don't know what happened
we were getting off an off-ramp and I
was I think in the back seat and he just
rear-ended a car just ran did somebody
like you do but there was that one time
in Mexico
he's got like a SUV and they used to
live in Mexico
and he's driving on the freeway in
Mexico like way over the speed limit so
fast that we're taking a sharp turn and
you can feel the tires are lifting
oh my god I said you could feel it being
like right my mom's in the car I'm in
the car he lives in the credits and
first time you guys in there right
sort of so imagine to impress er imagine
that imagine that this is you how you're
behaving around your son first time
you're meeting is serious and we're all
yelling my mom's going crazy we're all
yelling Gary and ela it doesn't even
know my dad I mean while my dad is so
crazy it's there silently doesn't even
acknowledge it continues to rip these
turns
it's weird I knew it was scary and my
dad he's he's on the road he what do you
see I don't know if you guys know about
like college rivalries yeah he went to
UCLA University of California they're
rivals in LA is USC they're like huge
sports rivals so his license plate said
hates SC and still I think maybe Tuesday
so when he sees some on the road with
the USC license plate like holder
license cut them off and I swear to you
with [ __ ] chill J in the car and both
family he will cut off another person on
the boat with his as if they were as if
they were not the Orphic sickness that's
scary scary sweet guy though anyway what
are your parents like your parents have
any crazy quarks like a teacher that's
crazy
[Laughter]
no she's a she I guess she has an excuse
because she's a teacher that is I mean
if you're a teacher for like four
five years you're like your mental
patient just keep going it's just like
worse than worse
what grade this you teach ah thanks for
stealing second or third oh wow let's
stop she used to teach middle school or
high school think high school and middle
school middle school was way worse she's
scary to me high school high school is
really bad middle school is really bad
yeah not the greatest which one's the
craziest middle school or second grade
think high school and middle school yeah
let's think in the fights yeah you're
like middle schools got to be the work
is dangerous right dangerous mines
what's that actress his name in
Dangerous Minds
you know that movie right she was like
this like pretty young blond teacher
who's teaching in like the hood that the
poetry one there could have been poetry
mmm Michelle Pfeiffer oh I didn't know
that it's called dangerous hell yeah
baby I love that movie throw that up let
me show you what your mom is up to her
Dangerous Minds gotta remember watching
this says it couldn't be in like damn
she's so cool oh she connects with
trench Oh can't really wear trench
coasters at school anymore so it's just
like real life
yeah it's like a mess constant right in
the chalkboard we want to die oh [ __ ]
it's Christ out we choose to die oh I
get it straight buster your mom do any
lessons like that think so but I think I
think middle school is the worst because
they're like in middle school you're
such a piece of [ __ ]
mm-hmm in high school you're starting to
learn a little bit that's true that
you're an idiot
yeah yeah you're still an idiot though
yeah full blown button it'll fall right
yeah Jason's mom looks just like him
well he looks like his mom it's cute
yeah they have the same like mouth and
nose kind of so I've got I'm trying this
new thing when we start our podcast
we're doing this thing called goof of
the day I've got some clips lined up and
I want to watch with you guys okay the
first one is DJ Khaled at performing at
an overwatch league it's great what I
love about this is that he's perfect
like DJ Kyle's not a performer right
like the tight man so imagine like
Flavor Flav without a band or anyone to
back them up with actual musical palette
it's just on a stage yeah it's crazy
here we go by the way you know they
frame this up so like there's like ten
people actually waving their arms well
the rest of the room is just like not
interested at all damn it's like Justin
Bieber is not there singing yeah DJ
count which is the worst part of every
music video
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like are you serious right now
that's a good question oh it's the phone
light no but you people are holding
their phones up there making it look
like they're holding their phones up no
way people have their phones out boys a
wristband it's probably like an event
wristband got it yeah it's there as well
going it looks confused you need to bet
you can't do DJ Khaled without the rest
of the band you know I mean like dj
khaled shouting another one is it
another where these have plants by the
way these guys were paid to dance dude
you're not even saying it damn
that's happening at this point may
really get your own concert but like
concert you you think that this could go
on for two hours straight having the
courage to yeah like a blizzard hired
them probably pay I mean I don't think
you can I was at all the performances
blizzard that was probably the number
one the most but you I mean speaking of
hip-hop you are kind of a hip-hop
musical performer now yeah your new
video came out chicken or chicken wings
right no I mean people are loving
chicken wings I love it let me play yeah
I was loving that by the way I'm curious
let me just play it for reference did
you make this beat yeah I mean are you
serious waiting for months row that beat
is is so insane Oh what is it that's
just
[Applause]
it's kind of subtle oh yeah
damn you can just rip his beat like that
and put some chicken wings okay I said I
could that's what it's in the
description the video pulling up okay
you'll see it's legit search thank you
rapping Gambini first day that I can
make this thought can you imagine
getting sued for this please well your
let me give you a sample of this in same
Ben same rapping I love the backup
vocals you offer that you're exhaling
you're obviously a poppy fan right is
your favorite genre of music
what else do you like R&B
yeah [ __ ] you are black I think you
totally correct
you and Callie I mean you should
elaborate I love that this is my credit
card dope so good you like shakes new
album oh you [ __ ] with Drake I don't
listen to family like two albums in the
whole year
really so you don't listen that much
music mm-hmm last time you told me if I
wrote one season two is real into really
what are you really into right now
Stevie Wonder what else
just just Stevie Michael Jackson yeah
he's gonna try to go see some guy oh
yeah then one guy come I see Washington
you hear him
a saxophone player can you find a clip
of that Dan Aryan I want to hear it
right now
come on see one I love Stevie but like
have you how long have you been
listening to Stevie or did you just kind
of get into it so you you've been riding
the Stevie and Michael train for a long
time do you share his musical tastes
well yeah because he controls the CDs
musical taste if you had control in the
CDs what would you play I have one CD
versus sweat six yeah I don't know I
tend to just listen to like whenever it
comes on like the student radio or like
something like kind of different like
all the time so I mean if I had to say
all-time favorites actually I really
like Lana Del Rey which is like I know
she one of the ones that she one of the
ones that died or something she's like
yeah that's kind of the only like pop
like dang listened to I listened to a
lot of like 90s music I guess yes
there's the radio station that his bird
noises what's it called they're talking
about like Oh cats are the leading
killers of birds cats are the leading
there's a lot of bird watchers I've
heard that that like nice trip like cats
are actually decimating what do you know
if bird radio gets affected
here's this here's this music that they
dunk use interior let's see what we got
if you write any really really bad
blocks don't kind of a block on there is
that Internet Explorer you just you in
you out you open it with me
Internet Explorer looks like well it's
it's set to default like break I'm using
discord and I click a link when what
world would I want to open anything
Internet Explorer you see it's a total
disaster you know our sponsors pay us a
lot of money to get their ads on our
show and here they didn't pay me [ __ ]
don't download that you're seeing this
guy in concert this is your guy what's
his name
I'm Ashley Washington what's going on
with him he looks very like bohemian
he's cool as hell actually I danced it
man I interviewed him shot an interview
with him
was the was it an interesting interview
yeah yeah it was just talking about his
musical background and everything is you
know it comes from like the jazz world
but he kind of crossed over with all of
the brain feeder you know and Flying
Lotus and those people yeah yeah no he's
cool as [ __ ] do you say like Thundercat
yeah yeah yeah wonder cat and all those
guys sick you're all about you like that
soul like that soul music did you hate
Jews do you hate this I'll take the
trumpet for me
I got another video lined up another
goof of the day because I couldn't
decide between DJ Khaled and all of the
Mexican workers going on strike
and this guy filming it and losing his
mind about it okay good stuff lined up
guys
only the best video a Mexican together
[ __ ] so let me know anything about who
filmed so the story is that they're on
some kind of smelting plant and two of
the dudes I guess their boss supervisors
are calm yeah
comrades was their colleagues got fired
or sent home for some reason so they all
packed up and said [ __ ] this you know
salt solidarity so this guy who's
working with it I guess there's a bunch
of Mexicans and a couple black dudes so
this is one of the black dudes who's in
awe of the Mexican camaraderie and
spirit back they say don't be shut this
[ __ ] down playing with this
black people need to be own man I swear
I gotta learn
take the sim and look at this man by the
way god bless him
I mean jokes aside for documenting this
I'm with him dude that's cool it's
probably gonna get married
oh yeah he's fired oh yeah he'll never
work again I love it dude I'm with them
I'm in solidarity yeah so we need why
the hell do you think apples worth a
trillion dollars no unions they don't
have unions in China I don't think what
do you guys think about Apple being
worth a trillion [ __ ] dollars why are
you an apple man no iPhone though your
aunt your [ __ ] your foots in the
water you like Apple we don't really
have an opinion on it I guess well it's
very and we would have to look I don't
want to take any you know radical I
[ __ ] hate I'm using it very sparingly
waiting for the right going it yeah you
can you can use that just sucks that I
understand like I've all come you can
keep it of all companies in the world
how is it that Apple was the one that
got a trillion I mean what are they
doing that just yeah they're the most
money the most valued company of all
time the first company ever to be worth
the trillion dollars I mean there they
sell [ __ ] harkening
[Music]
many [ __ ] iPhones are they selling I
get it though cause everyone's obsessed
with the iPhone all over the world right
and their computers too
so it's like yeah I get it it's
expensive too like how the hope people
afford that [ __ ] but that means to me
that like their margins are insane
that they probably are exploiting hell
of people for those margins to be so
insane you know what I'm saying like for
someone to make a million dollars is
hard enough you have to like step on a
couple throats along the way they make
forget about it billion a billion
there's a couple hookers in your pool
under your pool whatever yeah there's
definitely something at least several
hundred immoral things happening yeah
Sachs is not being Oh Apple is notorious
but it's not just them and so every big
I was watching CNN they're doing this
whole clip about like God I just outed
myself for watching CNN so anyway
they're doing this whole thing about
like celebrating that Apple made a
trillion dollars and it's like yeah
they're doing this whole thing about
they were talking about in a very like
glorious way it wasn't like they were
doing party poppers and [ __ ] yeah
counter on the wall but like I don't
know what's the exact figure but they
have evaded so much money
tanks axes yeah like how many a trillion
dollars how many shiny like I mean do it
that's just Chinese lots of Chinese
people going down for those phones I
don't know what to say man lots of
Chinese people are going down for those
phones but it's okay
because they're Chinese you are
educating us we're newcomers to the
trillion dollar industry what crickets
that's all I need to wind us down here
on the sound button I'm curious you guys
ever worked like a normal office job
like yeah you guys did what did you do
before you were the sweetheart of
YouTube worked at a nursing home
seriously yeah from my heart
no way what was your day-to-day uh dude
stuff on the computer like take old
people to therapy they're like pushing
my route yeah
you ever do any dirty work oh well
you're not supposed to but like you
member you have to do it cuz it's just
like so much stuff to deal with and
there's not enough people you know yeah
it's really stressful
I can't they're like I want to go on my
chair and it's like don't touch old
people you're gonna break their back if
you [ __ ] touch a metal right it's
like then they start getting it by
himself like no you can't do that
craziest thing that happened how long
did you work there uh-huh
not that one every more than a little
more than a year what was the craziest
thing that that you saw there ah one
time I heard a lady she was like she
would only she can only say like one
thing she was like oh hey something I
forget what she says she says I can name
one friend Marcus hello Marcus and I
could like this here like one time I was
walking and I could just hear like
really [ __ ] I opened up the elevator
and she's just sitting in there by
herself
hello Martin I'm like oh [ __ ] she was
like elevator that's such a hard job
yeah that's kind of sad yeah I'm Jin
they're probably not that long that's so
much some must have put her in yeah
elevators just you know does whatever
the [ __ ] at once okay other people
trained professionals actually yeah I
think you have a motivation yeah Nursing
gonna that's a tough thing dude yeah
change it a grown person like up yeah
damn that's a thankless job yeah like
that takes a lot of compassion to take
up human [ __ ] out of a diaper not a chat
not your own child you didn't take any
[ __ ] out of diapers no I was I had
probably the easiest job in that whole
building and you know it's pretty
stressful yeah what about yeah mine a
few things like well since high school I
had worked at like a convenience store
basically well it was technically a
co-op but like they just sell a lot of
like food and snacks and stuff I don't
know I worked there on and off for like
four years I guess but just I would like
go like to college and stuff for the
semester and come back and work so it
wasn't like full-time ever but yeah and
then the most recent um job I had was at
a bakery like a patisserie actually I
was just like in the front sometimes
that would help with like decorating
stuff or whatever they needed help with
Dubay not really it was like a Frenchman
that I have a degree in French so yeah
ya know like I didn't have like you know
any kind of job to do with that so that
was kind of like there were customers
who would like speak French with me and
like the pastry chef spoke French and
stuff so it was just kind of like you
know that's kind of how I got into that
job do you still work are you guys no
I'm well I run in the online store
dancin
that how every how recently were you
doing that the bakery job when was it it
was like yeah I'm talking that you had
like yeah it would've been the winter
before last
yeah and the only reason I quit was
because they shut it down they were like
yeah it was so weird they didn't like
tell us anything leading up to like
shutting it down they were just like
we're gonna have a staff meeting like on
Friday like everyone has to come oh
that's and then he was like so actually
it shut down and that's the last well
you know throw it to a break
when we come back we've got no Your Meme
coming up it's gonna be insane don't go
away
that's right good job see you guys soon
thank you to you to me for sponsoring
this episode of the H Street podcast
guys that matrix is no longer a fantasy
because with you to me we are plugged
right the F in okay these guys are the
largest learning marketplace they've got
courses really excellent courses on
everything from comic book drying to
programming professional fields whatever
you can dream up they've got courses for
you you don't need to go to college and
drop $100,000 anymore you don't have to
show up at 8 a.m. with a bunch of people
you don't like to learn from somebody
that doesn't want to teach you do it at
your own time at your own pace the same
level of learning even better because
you composite and continue another time
when you actually want to learn you
don't sit in a class for three hours yes
I didn't like college it was up to me
I'd go back in time do you to me
cost me a heck of a lot less and I
probably be a lot smarter too they've
got over 65,000 courses match that I
went I wanted to learn a little bit
about reason this music production
software they've got this guy teaching
me courses they got a whole syllabus
video video video video even does q and
A's to help you navigate if you have a
question you can drop a line to the
professor what more
you need they've got this coolest thing
too with the transcription of the video
if you want to find a specific place in
a video you can search through the
spoken video and find the right spot oh
I can't do that during a lecture I guess
I'll just fail this test guess what
there's no tests because you're learning
because you want to ever heard of that
called learning because you want to yeah
that's what udemy is all about go to ude
dot my / H through right now get 90% off
are you kidding me when I did a
university ever offer me 90 percent off
save eighty thousand dollars today when
you sign up for classes you will not
find a better price so sign up for
classes right now using my link ude dot
my slash h3 and get access to
life-changing classes for 90% off and
make sure you download their app for
your phone so you can stream your
studies wherever you are that's udem my
/ h 3u de dot my / h3 guys give them a
shot 90% off you got nothing to lose
except knowledge which you need a lot of
go learn you hear the angels singing
what is it that's on their breath honey
that's right honey
this has got to be one of the greatest
plug-in adventures of all time you plug
it in with a couple of clicks and it
automatically searches the entire web
for coupons as you shop it saved me
hundreds of dollars and you Tooele
mm-hmm I mean for example I was just
going in buying shoes I was ready to
drop $300 that was the price all of a
sudden honey pops in like Batman and Han
and they're like oh by the way we found
a coupon code you just saved 50 bucks
that you didn't think you were going to
save until right now what you're
probably wondering how much money can
honey really save me they actually
crunched the numbers
turns out those of you who have already
downloaded honey for my link have
already collectively saved over a
hundred and two thousand dollars in the
past few months as an average of 25
dollars per person what that's insane
you may have so be thinking honey
doesn't work on sites that I shop at the
this honey works on over 30,000 sites
including Amazon eBay Newegg Razer
Walmart and more to the core and 30,000
more ela and one more today do you find
one more oh so the big question is how
is money
how is honey free well there's no catch
y'all honey gets a small Commission from
sites where honey saves you money so
it's always free and that's really all
there is to it
they hook people up in people in short
okay 10 million people trust and use
honey and save money all the freakin
time
here's a little treat for you guys we
actually teamed up with honey so if you
install it for free with two clicks
using our Lake Joann honey calm slash h3
if you head on over to Teddy fresh
within the next week you're gonna save
15% off your purchase at checkout boom
that's the power of honey hear that
exactly
so as I said head on over to join honey
dot-com / h3 to save 15% off teddy fresh
and to save tons of money everywhere
else on the Internet
I cannot endorse them enough I love them
they're great get honey for free right
now at join honey dot-com / a tree
that's join honey calm / h3
here that that's God smiting the
unbelievers who haven't yet used quip
against all of my advice all of my
pleading if you have not used quip if
you have not treated yourself to this
great wonderful invention that I love
this is going to be you
being struck down by lightning by God's
wrath quip is just essential my friends
it's changed everything you know about
oral hygiene and trust me you know very
little and you don't need to know much
because this is all you need this
incredible vibrating toothbrush starts
at just $25 Wow
compared to other electric toothbrushes
are the size of a car battery that
started probably like at least ten
thousand maybe not that much but like a
couple hundred bucks you don't need all
that because in this little cylinder is
a vibrating little motor that's gonna
keep your teeth clean and your breath
smelling fresh here's what it does first
of all let's not get ahead of ourselves
because it's got these soft incredible
bristles I hate when the bristle is too
hard or too long and it irritates your
gums because guess what guys you can get
your teeth worked on but gums don't grow
back and that should horrify you gums
don't grow back true you need a good
toothbrush or you have so much problems
ahead for you so much dude this
toothbrush this clip is everything soft
bristles you turn on the vibration it's
three minutes of brushing boom buck
fifty on one side buck fifty on their
side it vibrates and pulsates to let you
know when to switch sides it basically
encourages you times you out without you
thinking to give yourself the perfect
brush if you're not using this item I
can't help you any more than I love this
thing and I'm telling you it's gonna
change everything you know quip starts
at twenty five dollars and if you go to
get quip comm /h through right now
you'll get your first refill pack free
with a quip electric toothbrush that
means the head pops right off every
three months you pop a new head on
you're good to go
that's your first refill pack free at
get equipped comm / h3
spelled g ET q UI p.com / h3 trust me on
this one guys get quit welcome back
everybody to another episode of know
your me special episode because our
guest the feature is one of the same
that is right video game dunkey sits
with me today is going to be the subject
of no you're mean how does that feel how
do you feel to be part of the show so
i'm going to be on this thank you this
is probably the best thing in my life
congratulations that's great love to
hear that it's really hard for me to
host and VJ you like you guys I've got
one help me on this I'm gonna stick with
it we're gonna do this we're gonna get
this right okay crickets on that this is
the one I'm really excited about I want
to do like this where you hit the left
track and it stop is really fast know
your meme that's right let's go to our
first caller oh thank you Dan appreciate
that Steve is on the line Steve hello
and welcome to know your meme you're on
the air hello how are you doing there we
look guys hey what's up Andy bin how you
doing where you from who are you anyway
I'm from New Jersey um you know just
just a boy out there trying to live
absolutely absolutely
we know that so Stephen tell me are you
a fan of video game donkey I am well you
passed our screening test in our intern
gave you he endorsed you greatly
and so with that being said I think
you're ready to play Know Your Meme all
right there we go tense music is
beginning Stephen music he
together oh we got what is donkeys
favorite video game is it a mario 64 be
bookworm adventures deluxe or see
ocarina of time Steven Wow
take a moment you know I thought I
thought it would have been I thought it
would have been act 2 or super mario
brothers 2 but they're not off you see
then we've got a mario 64 be bookworm
adventures deluxe or see ocarina of time
gonna be well with or is it be we're
gonna go with in Super Mario 64 what was
that Super Mario 64 Super Mario 64 and
the answer is and it was neck - actually
Mario 64 so
dunkey I would have guessed ocarina of
time but that would have been wrong but
it's Mario 64 through and through
yeah I guess I guess your answer
basically any Mario game is it's all
right question stuff one you didn't even
he knows yeah Steven let's move it on to
question two you're on the board you've
got one point how you doing feeling good
I'm feeling good I'm ready to go all
right bring it to the tent what is video
game donkeys favorite dish is it a
spaghetti and meatballs spaghetti and
meatballs now Steven I haven't finished
do you want me to continue with the
choices or you really want to lock that
in music music good getting a little
cocky here Steven all right I'm gonna
lock you in you just wanted to say it
you got the LS here lucky so here I like
is it a spaghetti and meatballs B tacos
or C pizza getting me pot now I'm a
little nervous actually I was doing it
maybe deeper than the me maybe it's
maybe it's not spaghetti and meatballs
well Steven you would probably yeah
there's other options than a I'm gonna
stick with my answer is spaghetti and
meatballs
even after you saw how they push back on
me as I drag my pension is it spaghetti
and meatballs oh [ __ ] no no a man a few
words you lose what is the real answer
it was tacos the whole time he's your
superfan you may know that yeah you may
you look like a taco guy what do you
like on your tacos what kind of tacos
you like wine for don't tell me about
your dream talk okay we're gonna have
some ground beef on there some lettuce
cheese oh then I'm gonna put some salsa
on out whoa what kind of salsa some
fresh salsa possible with the sour cream
okay black emollient okay if your
favorite fruit is tacos why don't we
just buy Mexican food for dinner your
hearing comes do it yeah you know what
I'm saying yes you do you usually just
eat Mexican food when you're here
because you love Mexican food since
we've been here really he loves them
even the beans we call them breakfast
nachos and rap you know what I do though
have a twist I asked him to put the
chips on the side cuz I don't like when
they get so soggy
he has a rule never ordered delivery
nachos oh yes mark that's a fool there's
nothing sadder than a sake soggy nacho
from here for me isn't it general just a
general tricking thank you
let's just get Mexican food you [ __ ]
with any other Mexican dish let's get
back to the game you will you [ __ ] with
burritos quesadillas you your taco man
strictly um I do it on your Mexican food
number-one cuisine why don't you guys
live in LA your Mexican food boy have
you been in Mexico Steven what's your
favorite cuisine oh man that's a tough
one you know honestly my answer is tacos
you knew went for spaghetti meat
remember it's about a real man behind
the moon you gotta get through the
layers here if you know when do you like
second maybe do it yeah do you like
squealing meatballs even not really no
it's really it's really on the chef you
know you gotta you gotta bring that dead
spice you got to bring that a little
[Laughter]
we're all we're all right there with
[Applause]
all right so what are we at we have one
point on the board okay what's going
yeah we got to make that so Steven let's
go back to the tension music we got one
point okay we got one strike not the
word a lifeline well he's got three
tries to get two more okay he doesn't
have a lifeline but chances are he's
gonna win this phone yeah yeah yeah you
know what I mean we like to do favors
but if you if you miss all of them
there's not much I can do for you I mean
I assume you want this brand new Galaxy
S nine plus as a thousand dollar phone
top of the line you want this really
dealer it isn't the best phone on the
market and Samsung wow what a great
company love them a lot Jason looks like
he wants one do you want this phone I
get it okay action rising question
number three what race is donkey a
Puerto Rican be black or to see white it
comes down to this right I'll let you
know what be on deck your time your I
see you're in it I want to hear your
thought process poor Rican black for
white alright well my thought process is
the meme is black so the me me answer
would be to answer black right mmm-hmm
and to be honest if they could just be
honest I can't I did think that you were
black when when I first started I
totally was disappointed a little
disappointed I'm being honest when I
found like this is a white guy so I
don't know if I should answer white or
black well no I'm not looking for a real
true
yeah a real answer yeah it's not if I
would I would have to go like wait
boom what is the real answer uh
black obviously do not have eyes he's a
black man actually the real answer is
Puerto Rican no oh boy no it's why you
have two points you're on the board you
are looking really good that was a tough
one
yeah yeah that had me stressing I wasn't
sure what the answer was and I have
answer in front of me all right these
last two are honestly so easy if you get
the if you get I don't know let me play
the music now here we go what game did
dunkey get famous playing that later
banned him and has since rapidly
declined in popularity to almost
complete obscurity a game no one cared
about or plays today what is the name of
that awful forgotten game that is
falling off the face of the planet and
as basically zero players what is the
name of that game there is there is a
zit csgo a B League of Legends it's
almost as if I forgot the name of it or
co2 till we get to the best part of the
fog
[Music]
I'm Randy Wiremu be up there what'd you
say
League of Legends League of Legends it's
almost as if I barely you know yeah in a
way it's like who [ __ ] like do people
still play that game though I mean
seriously yeah yeah only in like China
right well they don't have like DJ
counted coming anymore right overwatch
got DJ college money now but like you
used to be known for playing league but
now I feel like that's ancient history
like doesn't that feel good that you got
away from that kind of videos yeah yeah
was that I mean were you thinking about
getting away from making those kind of
videos for a long time or was it just
like they were dicks and you [ __ ] off
kind of like a rest this isn't what I
was for the basket he didn't he was just
that like I was really scared that he
was gonna like weird drastic change
right away but he's just like well I was
scared too the truth is like well there
was a bunch of people who were making
League videos but that's kind of like a
dead thing now isn't it it wasn't really
like it's on the downhill yeah stolen
but they don't Sega Rises can you say
rise
and by the way Steven congratulations to
you we don't even need to read the fifth
question which frankly isn't really a
good question anyway we need three yeah
you're a winner
brand new Samsung Galaxy S nine plus
what phone are you currently using I'm
using an iPhone and it doesn't work very
well send us back of the suspend back
thank you for calling in Steven Wayne
thank you for being a great contestant
good job and
pursuer of dunkey mythology hmm thank
you so much
make sure you stay on the line all right
love it
I was talking with you guys before know
your man which by the way so much fun
that was scared you know you shown the
line jeez God all right you keep messin
with this guy for Stephen we had like
that funnier ice cream you know yeah I'm
like they keep giving you the ice cream
and flippin eventually you just at what
point do you just walk away from that
situation because it is familiar I would
have probably left early yeah well not
from this no man nice you know we talked
about you know let me treat you like
trick I guess but I think you know what
you're getting in bold you mode you call
that ice cream prankster ice cream like
Street like okay funny thing it's always
like I know you guys are talking about
really I gotta find it ice cream trick
like an ice cream truck guy just [ __ ]
with people dude this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you know by the time it's been in this
pocket it's been on so in short that's
what that's how what we weigh I'm trying
to yeah I know any much funny yeah it's
good gotta love those ice cream
gentlemen a parallel universe but do you
think you could pull that off I feel
like you're a scream gentleman and I
care little universe we're talking about
dinner I didn't know you're so
passionate about Mexican food I'm very
passionate about Mexican food yeah yeah
your taco taco master he knows how to
make really good salsa yeah dude
what nobody say nobody knows that's like
that's like like a desired skill among
[ __ ] well I so I have one specific salsa
I'm very good at the red and all this
mystery stuff I'm not very good at but I
make a great avvocato green salsa that
is excellent but I'm thinking we should
just order
you know I'm saying get some nachos you
can't order nachos no nachos unless you
get them to chip Sempron all right
nachos with chips separate that because
mixing order but I was just talking
about how this morning I'm so tired I
woke up because I've been preparing for
you guys's visit last time you hear we
had we cooked dinner it was so much fun
great Ethan's amazing chef
you guys were loving it we have made it
sounds like you gotta make it it's so
fun cooking for people who are like
appreciative I was like damn I'm gonna
pull all the stops for these guys so I
was think games while I woke up at 5:00
a.m. this morning I baked chocolate chip
cookies you can smoke up your ass
these are insane and I was gonna bring
some for the guy the guys yeah but I was
like not enough cookies honestly and I
and I bring that up I bring that up
because I want you to know that you guys
are so cookie but the new thing I'm
working on is baking yeah I'm working on
learning how to make sourdough bread oh
yeah you tell me about that
and it's like it's so intense and it's
so time-consuming you have like a good
starter I made a my own starter okay
from scratch nice I think it's in a good
shape what made really good Brendan last
Friday it was like professional well I
have made two breads one was great one
was like perfect the first one the
second one was of literal brick but
still good was like you could it was
good yes first bricks got me the flavor
is very important it was good texture
was off so I can't wait I started
getting that starter yeah bread is like
my favorite food I did anyway
I bro
the dough I proved it proved it some
more it's in the proving basket now it's
in the fridge this one because the the
starter was bubbly and I see a rash it
was like really good smell and texture
and this morning I was kneading the
dough and it was just looking really
good and so I did a little twist because
I didn't want to over prove it
mother what proving people don't know is
when you leave the dough out for several
hours and the yeast eats the flour so it
starts to rise and make it fluffy and
turn it sour so it does all the magic so
you prove it I didn't want to over prove
it so I popped it in the fridge that's
the twist good I don't know if it's
gonna work but it should know if I buy
in today is terrible I really like it
though it's so wholesome cuz ela is like
the pickiest eater ever she loves bread
and the bread here in America is so bad
yeah I have no problem with them bread
here so just a roll but so yeah I want
to see it plain bread no the bakery I
worked out was also a sourdough bakery
like specifically sorry no nice yeah so
I got a lot of free bread there so the
thing that that we particular here I
mean you uh is that there's so much
sugar like if you go to the store yeah
bakeries have got it going on generally
like in a good way but at the store it's
like I've noticed you'll get a hotdog
bun and it's got 6 grams of sugar in it
yeah I don't know we try to buy like
local bakeries that's sweet yeah we
don't really have a bakery so you guys
are on the you guys are killing it on
breads well we try that the grocery
store they don't even have like local
bake
like bakeries stuff at your grocery so
there's always they're always dry yeah
almost rouse like Ravis makes their own
bread and it's like you know the rouse
lady she doesn't really care what's
going on in that low thanks to you know
what I mean yeah not like a bakery not
fresh it's not like artisan they're
[ __ ] around back there they don't
think they don't think it's Sarah
Manning on the ceiling don't take it on
my hands so doesn't stick I'm neat I've
needed this dough I don't think they're
doing that definitely not doing this on
is coming up I'm in the kitchen I'm
downstairs sweating oh my hand is
unusual because I knew you guys were
calling I wanted to you know I want to
do the right thank you but the question
is now that I've learned that you're
such a Mexican food fanatic which I
appreciate so much is do because I was
originally planning to cook some filet
mignons I don't know I'm gonna give you
the option I think this is you guys kind
of a side conversation I'm in the food
god I hope you like my bread coz your
seems like you're in deep in the bread
world so this is gonna be a real test
for me yeah I'm gonna eat it plain I'm
gonna eat it with butter
I mean we're prepared you're not we love
please
we bought butter salted of course French
yeah very nice and jelly fats and cream
cheese obviously yeah yeah
I don't usually have cream cheese on
bread you know it's a killer wine it
cream cheese and jelly I've had that a
sandwich that's right it's really good
so back to the meats because the bread
was that sorted no you look what yeah
we're we're one course down don't jump
the gun okay so I think that my
specialty is definitely cooking steaks
so I can do that but also I mean Mexican
food can't go wrong
can't go wrong steak talk you could you
can very yeah you can very go wrong
there's a lot of bad places so if we
order there's a chance it's gonna be bad
it's probably gonna be good dance
because that's what I'm yeah okay
oh yeah Mexican food in Wisconsin no
that can't be that is there good Mexican
food
there's some good people out there are
they Mexicans yeah okay produce is not
as good that said no Dan are you
speaking to Mexican food in Wisconsin
dan yeah I might be speaking out of turn
cuz I mean I've never been to Wisconsin
[Laughter]
by the way I like their urgency of you
to send me a damn thank you know
[Laughter]
sometimes it's a sin
yeah you have interesting video almost
yeah if people are listening to this if
anybody's left Leslie with this they're
gonna love that idubbbz made a really
great video about like burrito density
did you see that it's so good video
analyzing the content of burritos in San
Diego and it was like so [ __ ] great
opens up the brew doesn't analyze is so
good that's dedication moments the
conclusion well he was analyzing like
three different major chains and like if
they're making them right sometimes
Believe It or Not they put french fries
and Rios oh you throw mint no you know
uh you know you got yeah you're like
burrito burrito we got burger we go we
go yeah that sounds like some yeah
sounds like some whiskey and that's so
tough so do they put ketchup in it like
my nightmare if it's really dedicated to
being a hamburger I have a problem with
some french fries in there that's not
okay no it's a wrap
it's just a wrap yeah it's just a wrap
it's if you call it a wrap it's much
easier for me to handle
[Music]
I was like I will not eat that like I'm
still gonna try it and he got it he was
like you can do it so the mistake camp
I'm the same way oh I hate it and I'll
eat it Ilana they I don't I don't even
touch it yeah that's why we look like
Miguel I'm actually I'm not kidding I
eat two portions of every meal or like
one because she's happy it's pretty
event I end up starving if I if it
doesn't look perfect to me yeah
not that anything it's not that I want
to do it I just can't like I can't eat
it
I hear you it's just you know you're
built from a different cloth I have a
problem of my food falling apart and
then it's too messy for me that's a
problem at the restaurant like the
waiter is going
and I'm like here give me that like she
was all done with that burger and it was
like the whole burger was still there
with all the stuff and I like had my
whole plate is clear I'm a give me that
and right when the waiters I'm just
taking her old plate and start shaming
that yeah I could look funny
you're like an abuse like a abusive food
hoarder your time is up give me a
birthday surprise I'm sure I do that
Fela but like i i'll i i can hate and
eat so easily i'll not even like it and
it's bad for me and it's super
high-calorie
i'll [ __ ] eat that [ __ ] before you
look blinks that's the worst on this
like this bed with a taste bed and it's
also there were youth at its source
that's what disney is all about it the
corndog you know the strange like combo
or something like it on a corndog i felt
pretty bad about that well not according
acts but a second two thousand cows oh
yeah oh the leg no I got a I did get the
leg by the way oh you got one
okay okay this says 400 calories I'm
here to say that's a [ __ ] outright
lie whole [ __ ] that is a outright
monstrous lie this corn dog is the size
of the threader oh yeah I gotta find out
I got to get to the bottom of this can
you guys find out what's the calories
not man Steven Fortin
that's a monstrous [ __ ] yeah it's
like this big like for anyone who has
not had it's and it's deep-fried corn
it's awesome I feel like that's 1,200
calories oh yeah do you guys hear about
there was this mega bucks jackpot was
543 million bucks no damn so this was
like a huge jackpot in California and 11
employees at one store all went in
together on tickets and they won so
basically all the employees at this one
place are now overnight worth like 60
million in piece I was just thinking
like that place is going out of business
but everybody's [ __ ] gone it's such a
funny situation it's like this what its
gonna be like funny to think like that
they're all playing the lottery so they
can never see each other ever again
these [ __ ] guys eleven of them yeah
that article says every single one of
them said they have no intention on
quitting get real what do they I really
love my job as a receptionist I'm worth
18 million dollars now and I have no
intention of leaving my job as a
receptionist some people really like
going out to work it's like I know my
mom is like that like on on Saturday
she can't in Israel you go back to work
on Sunday so on Saturday she can't wait
for Sunday like I've never heard anyone
say that they only have one day uh-huh
yeah she says what she always says I
can't wait for Sun they're serious that
amaura different different alien race
what the hell is she an alien right
there
you think if your mom 129 million US
dollars she would work at Delta still I
feel like she would say that but I
wouldn't believe it no effing way like
all these guys I think they need to
follow up with them in like two weeks
out there
what's that check it's the bank 29
million just really financially
conservative a option all 11 of them
have this option between they can
receive 18 is this right then 18 million
per year a 1.6 million per year forever
or a measly 29 million pop take the 1.6
right take the lump alumni I love all
day I think I'd like to belong because I
don't trust take the money and run yeah
inflation take the money and run I don't
want anyone own me money I take the lump
every time here's no it's just gonna win
the lotto I'm not ashamed to admit it I
bought four tickets
I dropped ten dollars on that beer like
tons of tickets probably they probably
pull it in and bought a bunch just like
for the only a handful that's a cheap
bugs bucks apiece 11 people so 22 bucks
they probably had a decent okay god
that's crazy
have you guys ever played lottery you
ever buy ticket and just fantasize what
if you were like a millionaire overnight
never
really no my mom used to always do this
thing where she buy when the lottery got
big she'd buy ticket and then from like
the whole week she would just talk about
fantasizing about it for the whole week
like I would move and I would do the
kitchen this way and like really
extended banner so getting you excited
wow maybe we are gonna win really I
don't know if you know and that is here
is it just like a ham p.m. I got a guy
yeah but yeah yeah so they they did the
lottery there and I just remember all
the old people going there and like
placing their bets and they're so
serious about it there's like combos and
right I'll do the X and there's like the
X combo and right I don't know I mean
even though it's completely random
I know people that win are you both
there is that like they're doing their
exam it's been three days it's the seven
was the first number can you imagine
though the amount of money to win is so
obscene half a billion dollars for
literally doing nothing it's hard to
that's why the jackpot is so hot cuz so
many people and bought into it you know
overnight one of the richest people in
the world how does that even what are
weird that's how it works they just they
make money by people buying tickets
makes the jackpot larger it's actually
the law I always win obviously the
lottery a lottery every night I'd say
the lottery is an interesting thing it
was I don't know where I learned about
this but it was made to be a public
service so like it's like a voluntary
tax literally that's how they thought
about it it originated in like Japan and
so you would be like give us a buck
have a chance to win a prize but the
money goes to civic services so like
they used the lottery money to fund
schools and local [ __ ] and that's still
what they do today
select the California Lottery is a is a
public fund used for the benefit the
welfare of the good it's a so like it's
a California State Lottery so it's run
by that because I've seen like you'll
see like an auditorium and it says it's
a voluntary tax
it's literally a voluntary tax pretty
cool growing up my dad always would tell
me it's the idiot tax whenever the
jackpot was huge like it was on this one
he would still go buy a ticket well my
brother explained it to me of mr.
science he goes at a certain point when
it gets so big you're actually
statistically a favorable bet you know I
mean let's say you have like a 1 and 10
million chance of winning and so usually
let's say the prize is 5 million bucks
and you buy a ticket so that's not a
statistically good say if you put $1 and
you stand to win half a billion and all
the sudden yeah yeah maybe there's logic
there
yeah wait if you don't play no one wins
nobody went oh I have a great video
about the lottery I want to watch with
you guys well there's another story I
want to talk about just cracked me up
vanilla almond breeze almond breeze you
guys drink almond milk yeah well you
don't you'll be horrified to know that
it's being recalled because there's
actually a trace amount of the real buck
in it some other day I was I had a port
a big old bowl of [ __ ] Honey Smacks
like this cereal that I know
I just picked it for some reason like oh
I'll have Honey Smacks and I'm like
we're driving home from Milwaukee I'm
like it's [ __ ] crazy radio stations
like on this goofy hip-hop station like
DJ Fresh yeah they just recalled Honey
Smacks
it has salmonella Salmonella you thought
I was gonna sell Manila no but it's not
[ __ ] hilarious they're making almond
milk the milk alternative and somehow
real milk is slipping into almond up how
does that happen
like your one mission do not have milk
idiot they're recalling 145,000 half
gallons of almond milk because they
could contain actual milk why there's no
information about why actual milk got
into the almond milk yeah try to dig
into it and just nobody nobody has any
excuse it's like a great mystery just
cracks I happen I just love the idea of
somebody going to buy almond milk cause
they're like a vegan or something and
there's just a trace amount of real milk
mm-hmm it's like a local banks they're
like hey Adam disgruntled worker just a
little milk that's like that's not like
a little mistake that's like like a
[ __ ] like a month of [ __ ] how long
does that go on yeah I don't know
they're recalling a lot of milk and why
does the almonds have to pay for the you
know I'm a I'm a nice defenseless
almonds are going down with it
Jason was freaking out about the cereal
he thought they're like rubbing raw
chicken on the cereal wasn't it cooked
like it touched like every piece of the
sea really like yeah
some 30s guy at the factory who probably
takes his [ __ ] cooks chicken without
washing his hands and he's handling the
smacks like it's goop it's got raw
chicken goop in your smacks oh man half
a ton of videos to watch Jesus we're all
over the place talking about our dinner
plans thank you for reminding me we're
doing both right I think I'll get steaks
and we'll order [ __ ] Mexican food
dude this is gonna be so good we got
cookies I'm gonna make cocktails you
guys like Moscow Mule yes we just got
the tin cup we got fresh brass re they
like the artisan bread and wake up at
5:00 and the cook you bread you look
sorry they sound like a hipster
well I'm literally sweating as the Sun
rises kneading dough thanklessly I think
that is really hipster of me speaking of
the law it was really nice to wake up
and have a fresh cookie have a wait
smell chocolate chip cookies waffle is
gonna expect this it's a one-day thing
you guys are the sweetest couple ever do
you guys fight about anything ever
laughs like what disagreements like
stupid no yeah but then we just like
laugh like if we look if we like make
eye contact then it good like we're good
like really is seriously gonna try to
like look at you trying to make yeah
maybe if we like separated and like went
in separate rooms or something we could
like have a bigger fight but we never
almost like you want to fight more like
you're working on a fight have you guys
like had a fight but you're not maybe if
we Jason maybe if you went in that room
and I go around each other text alright
let's let's watch this beef meaning you
always fight about food pretty much not
anymore
that you see earlier it used to be all
we fought about like what you telling
her to eat her like where do you eat cuz
ela I don't know why we argued so much
about it because like it's hard it's
hard - yeah I come from like my mom
usually cooks all the time so growing up
I only ate at home so I ate I hate
eating outside and Ethan and grub the
opposite
Ethan ate how it like every time all day
right that's as I understand it yeah
that's kind of the thing so that is why
we would have a lot of like I wanted to
eat out yeah you don't like getting out
you don't hang out but we don't really
argue about it it doesn't matter anymore
I've learned to get home check this out
speaking of the lottery story is about a
moment was after barb Reddick and her
nephew Tyrone McGinnis picked up their
big win 1.2 million dollar chased the
ACE jackpot but it didn't take long for
things to turn sour when both were
handed separate checks for $600,000 JC
ace waiters is going to court
I've taken him to court it was Marty but
I bought the child and
trying to lawyer say I said split
I said split with the 50/50 not with no
JC ace I'm taking him to court I'll get
my lawyer
both names are on the winning ticket the
medic says he agreed to split the
consolation prize and not the jackpot
if the ace was drawn I put his name by
the thing I told him for good luck now
he's lying but I'm taking it to court
I'm serious I'm getting the lawyer
tomorrow
I put his name for good luck and I want
name work do you got the good luck like
Dan get a little [ __ ] money
you always hear these stories of you
know family's falling apart over this
but like over the course music keeps the
money how is he gonna enjoy it now he's
out he's [ __ ] peace now that's 600
that way what is she by the way this oh
I don't know where they live like I'm
sooo many where expensive like what is
this lady gonna do with six hundred
thousand bucks and he's gone she's gone
he's going to make plans together I
guess you're right
redo the kitchen could cost you anyway I
thought this was interesting just like
Dan yeah a couple bucks that's a quick
turnaround yeah because he's like a son
to me he watch it's almost like she
wishes she didn't win because then it's
like she'd almost rather that they
didn't win and then that they were still
like friends like it's ruined her life
what are they gonna do it's like you
just won $600,000 wouldn't you get in
and out spend half of it on attorneys on
the winning ticket the phone number was
mcginnises Brittany's curly says
she called to notify the winners no one
answered so she called a porn mm-hmm it
doesn't get better
mm-hmm you got all the good stuff I mean
I've got some other stuff here but we
really boss we really you know spent a
lot of time on the food which I don't
have regrets
tell me if you want to watch me of this
stuff I'm good we can wrap it up some
stuff but I've got Christian mom upset
by north-north have you seen that that's
an investment yeah
that's not I don't want to wait with
yeah it's an oldie because that was kind
of related to you writing your own
hip-hop song all right so I'm gonna put
on the Bremen so she heard this song by
Vince staples called north north on the
radio by the way a great song but as far
as hip-hop songs go it's really not the
worst one not even close
yeah I mean it's got a message right
feeling yeah anyway she's having like a
mental breakdown that I was playing on
the radio and the best she reads the
whole lyrics to the song with the best
part is that because she literally reads
every single lyric they were able to mix
it up so she's at some unis at there for
like 12 minutes reading and cries yeah
it's very [ __ ] you thirsty
these grandmas right
with you baby just don't move too fast
I'm too great man down from the entropy
mobile shaded take a [ __ ] mind off Matt
me I love her she dropped that and we
applied indiscriminately
every mode know the difference sandiana
Browns like the soap daddy shoe region
hello I don't even know if I pronounced
that right then that was the first verse
this is the main chorus says I ain't
never ran from nothing but the police
Vince staples had the best response
I don't you thought he was like he's
like I agree he's like your reactions
right like that's the point of the song
it's a good day you feel that way cuz
it's so [ __ ] up like that's right
you're getting the right reaction
society is so messed up listen to the
music we really don't need to watch all
this it's great okay it's got a lot of
it's got a love lore surrounding it on
the radio or something the fact actually
the fact that the little baby's behind
her she's saying it word for word it's
the same thing it's actually worse on
the radio you don't really catch all
she's like I can't believe my kids are
hearing this on the radio and she's
they're dropping and bombs and I was
awful shut invasion new video like
people don't really get how it works you
know old white people no I don't really
good like that it's like from a
character trying to figure out I think
everything is like like literal like
right says in the song I shot this guy
they think he literally shot the dude
right yeah oh my god
did the police looking into this yeah so
we got prank invasion new video moaning
edition let's check it out pretty bad
enough there's a seizure addition as
well
solid as you can imagine different
beaters crazier yeah since ours are his
piss oh yes Asian
yeah he's off the map pretty much I mean
he's got kissing my fans nursed edition
couples edition whipped cream addition I
think moaning edition you're gonna
you're gonna really enjoy this one
morning how does he think about it by
the way he's he's been working out a lot
more veins yeah way more rapey he's
looked at pong but like he's more
imposing now like if he wanted to like
rape me or dominate me you know I'm
saying like heat you like you're giving
him that [ __ ] kiss but the music
never changes something's changed you
see these biceps give me like a really
weird in creepy way and see what happens
as always let's do it as always it's a
really quick game of rock-paper-scissors
if I win I get to give you a really
quick kiss okay here we go
forget the hopefully
[Music]
at this point is this is not just comedy
why just to see what he just sounds like
he's having like a epileptic seizure is
that what it sounds like
all right Chris don't get my video
demonetised isn't the same noise each
time or does he do like a little
different quick kiss okay here we go
okay
rock paper scissors one more time here
we go
rock paper scissors I win come here as
always
[Music]
[Music]
the seizure I think he's really just
wrong
you know he knows I'm having a laugh I'm
sure this is the part that weird he's
parodying himself exactly like we made
that one video you know uh a closer look
yeah and now the lion was getting so
blurred that I was actually starting to
enjoy watching his videos cuz they're so
like the moaning one like it's you watch
it and it's so stupid
you know like there's a weird
transformation going I feel like if he
keeps following the thread of so obscene
so stupid that he could really be on to
a new way of entertainment yeah and
somehow it makes it girly the same way
good but I you know probably are you
buying that it's set up you know it's
just so I paid so there's one here let's
watch this last one this one I saw it
loved it how to stop cyberbullying it's
a big issue facing all of us today on
the Internet as you guys know you work
on their night live on the Internet
have you guys ever had problem with
cyber bullying all the time yeah yeah me
too it's tough on overwatch and some guy
was yelling at me about something
alright I was scared what are you doing
that point he's literally a helpless
leave I leave the house I have a hole in
my backyard laying when I get so well
anyway this we have a helpful tip for
you on cyber bullying
I think the best advice I received to
cyberbullying the way that she phrases
it almost sounds like she's gonna get
tips to the cyber voter I would get to
sign her believe
[Music]
[Laughter]
and I was a great advice yes she's
getting cyber bullying now ironically
let's go eat some dinner everyone go
love your mum everyone love so guys
thank you for all tuning in and watching
and enjoy sure uh that Wow
hold it together for another minute
we're almost done uh the next month is
looking pretty good
yeah Dan what do we got we've got Jenks
that's a guy jacksepticeye in a couple
weeks and then Bert Kreischer after that
and then this one's pretty big
we got Tim Heidecker coming on the 31st
which had a siren what enough boost em
hidin him freak really cool hat occur
yep
ya know with it and then the week after
that we got a Adam Corolla so Adam
Corolla also very cool thank you and
possibly well I won't say it cuz it's
not confirmed but right hey we got a
great lineup Jules
yes so next fight is probably
just house all right X Fridays just us
having fun with the sound boards you
guys are not gonna want to miss it
and with that bank focus guys thank you
so much for watching hope you have a
great weekend
so Joel love your mother guys have a
great weekend they care yourself
happiness is number one you got to do
what's good for you in your life you
mindful be aware of everything that
you're appreciative you know you know
constantly don't take anything for
granted
Blake of I could all go away I mean
seriously you don't you don't want a
list out of that I think the audience
will like if he does all right end it
then save us from ourselves
[Music]